ز
15 person
15শ
make
people care
are
as
gather
‏are now
make
cover
also
and from paring in the neப
a you don't see many of cars pleas ref
from it we have le paring for our own
needs অনলদলিল্লাহ
جزاك الله
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما
‏are
all na
time عليه السلامجال
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
‏moreending
moreing
finallyates
everything
from being and so
فتنهجال
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وسلمجال
‏any
[Silence]
‏and
speaks aboutad
of
there many narrationم
ابو داوداني
رحمه
الامام احمد بن حنبل
عبد الله ابن عمر رضي الله عنه وعن ابيه
صلى الله عليه
‏andulminate
of
the first mentions was الاحتate
of constant war and peace
فتنه السراء
فتنه الاحلاس
الاحلاس جمع حلس والحلس هو الذي يوضع على
ظهر على ظهر البعير حينما يركبه
ويكون يكون فوقه الساج
وسمي
بفتنه الاحلاس لطول مكثه على الامه
فتنه السراء
فتنه السراء فتنه السراء
الله
سوره الاعراف
وما ارسلنا في قريه من نبي الا اخذنا
اهلها بالباساء
الباساء الفقر والضراء الامراض هذه فتنه
الاحلاس
يقول
ثم بدلنا مكان السيئه الحسنه حتى عفوا
وقالوا قد مس اباءنا السراء والضراء
‏ee
whated
ease aized ease meaning people
comforable
comfort will be the
‏ising
to
the kind of comfor that breath
selfishness and selfindul
the kind of comfor that breeds
selfcenteredness
and breeds entitlement
until people are very used to this
comfor and this ised ‏will
things are things will
people
worried about you even beingot
peopleallyable
no other
prop
فتنه السراء
فتنه الدهيماء
تصغير دهماء
الدهماء
black
صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏people
anyore
from anyore
and
come
anotherist
howes
ثم تكون فتنه الدهيماء
لا تدع وجها الا صفعته صفعه
او لطمته لطمه
فتنه الدهيمات
‏will
face of
that will out and slap it.
Let me take a stop here for a second.
‏What is a slap when people fight? Do
they usually fight slapping each other
or do they usually fight punching each
other? Punching kicking what is the
purpose of a slap
disresect.
‏SL
صلى الله عليه وسلم
faceن
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه سلم
لا تدع وجها الا لطمته ايش
[Arabic recitation]
قال يصبح الرجل فيها مؤمنا ويمسي كافرا
حتى تكون الناس او حتى يكون الناس على
فسطاطين
فسطاط ايمان لا نفاق فيه وفسطاط نفاق لا
ايمان فيه ايش الفسطاط؟
فسطاط الخيمه
الخيمه يعني حتى يكون الناس هذول في
خيمتهم وهذول في خيمتهم حتى يكون الناس
مذهبين مذهب ايمان لا نفاق فيه ومذهب كفر
لا ايمان
مذهب نفاق لا ايمان فيه كذب وزور ودجل لا
ايمان فيه
[Silence]
يقول لا تدع وجها الا لطمته لطمه
ولا بيتا الا دخلته
فاذا
فاذا ظنوا نهايتها تمات
‏will
man upon
himat
[Silence]
فاذا كان ذلك فانتظروا الدجال من يومه او
غدجال
‏And so
the scholars of Islam
they
have always explained this narration and
you notice that up until recently
scholars would always write in their
explanations
اعلم
‏until what happen
what you think thisit might be what do
you think is
no not the fall of the think about it it
won a single face except that it slaps
it a man will awake a believer and go to
sleep as a disbeliever
‏Correct.
‏Can you think of a more fitting
description?
The schar
this has been acted and they have come
to consensus in modern day that this
narration is speaking about the internet
and the widespread falsehood that is
coming. And just when we thought it
couldn't get any worse,
chat GPT entered the chat.
‏Grock entered the chat.
GPT entered the chat. Google entered the
chat. AI entered the chat. And now weve
got people that think that AI is a god.
Some of them are worshing it. If I had a
nickel for every couple that came in and
said when we have problems, me and my
wife, we refer to the Quran.
‏GP
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده
ان شاء الله تعالى
والله اعلم الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
صلاه
ترا
[Silence]
الله
استقيم واعتدل استو
حلو
[Silence]
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
وقضى ربك الا تعبدوا الا اياه وبالوالدين
احسانا
انا يبلغن عندك الكبر احدهما او كلاهما
فلا تقل لهما اف
ولا تنهرهما
وقل لهما قولا كريما
واخفض لهما جناح الذل من الرحمه وقل رب
ارحمهما كما ربياني
صغيرا
ربكم اعلم بما في نفوسكم ان تكونوا صالحين
ان تكونوا صالحين فانه
كان للاوابين
غفورا
وات ذا القربى حقه والمسكين وبن السبيل
ولا تبذر تبذيرا
ان المبذرين كانوا اخوان الشياطين
وكان الشيطان لربه كثورا
واما تعرضن عنهم ابتغاء
رحمه
من ربك ترجوها
فقل لهم قولا ميسورا
ولا تجعل يدك مغلوله
الى عنقك ولا تبسطها كل البسط
ولا تبسطها كل البسط فتقعد ملوما
محسورا
ان ربك يبسط الرزق لمن يشاء
ويقدر
انه كان بعباده خبيرا بصيرا
ولا تقتلوا اولادكم خشيه الاق
نحن نرزقهم واياكم
ان
قتلهم كان خطا
كبيرا
ولا تقربوا الزنا انه كان فاحشه
وساء
سبيلا
ولا تقتلوا النفس التي حرم الله الا بالحق
ومن قتل مظلوما فقد جعلنا لوليه سلطانا
فلا يسرف في القتل انه
كان منصورا
ولا تقربوا مال اليتيم الا بالتي هي احسن
حتى يبلغ اشده واوفوا بالعهد ان العهد كان
مسؤولا
واوفوا الكيل اذا كلتم وزنوا بالقسطاس
المستقيم
ذلك خير
واحسن تاويلا
ولا تقف ما ليس لك به علم ان السمع والبصر
والفؤاد كل اولئك
كان عنه مسؤولا
ولا تمش في الارض مرحا
انك لن تخرق الارض ولن تبلغ الجبال طولا
كل ذلك كان سيء سيئه عند ربك مكروها
ذلك مما
اوحى اليك ربك من الحكمه ولا تجعل مع الله
الها اخر فتلقى في جهنم
فتلقى في جهنم
ملوما مدحورا
افاصفاكم ربكم
البنين واتخذ من الملائكه
اناثا
انكم
لتقولون قولا عظيما
ولقد صرفنا في هذا القران ليذكروا
وما يزيدهم الا نفورا
قل لو كان معه الهه كما يقولون اذا لبت
ابتغوا الى ذي العرش سبيلا
سبحانه وتعالى عما
يقولون علوا كبيرا
تسبح له السماوات السبع والارض ومن فيهن
وان من شيء الا يسبح بحمده ولكن لا تفقهون
تسبيحهم
انه
كان حليما
غفورا
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
واذا قرات القران جعلنا بينك وبين الذين
لا يؤمنون بالاخره حجابا مستورا
وجعلنا على قلوبهم اكنه ان يفقهوه وفي
اذانهم
عقرا
واذا ذكرت ربك في القران وحده ولوا على
ادبارهم نفورا
نحن اعلم بما يستمعون به اذ يستمعون اليك
واذ هم نجوى اذ يقول الظالمون ان تتبعون
الا رجلا مسحورا
انظر
كيف ضربوا لك الامثال فضلوا
فضلوا فلا يستطيعون
سبيلا
ربكم
انظر كيف ضربوا لك الامثال فضلوا
فضلوا فلا يستطيعون
سبيلا
وقالوا ائذا كنا عظاما ورفاه انا لمبعوثون
خلقا جديدا
قل كونوا حجاره او حديدا
او خلقا مما يكبر في صدوركم
فسيقولون
من يعيدنا
قل الذي فطركم اول مره
فسي
اليك رؤوسهم ويقولون متاهوا
قل عسى ان يكون قريبا
يوم يدعوكم فتستجيبون
بحمده وتظنون
ان لبثتم الا قليلا
وقل لعبادي يقول التي هي احسن
ان الشيطان ينزغ بينهم
ان الشيطان كان للانسان
عدوا مبينا
وربكم
ربكم اعلم بكم ان يشا يرحمكم او ان يشا
يعذبكم
وما ارسلناك عليهم وكيلا
وربك اعلم بمن في السماوات
والارض ولقد فضلنا بعض النبيين على بعض
واتينا داوود زبورا
قل ادعوا الذين زعمتم من دونه فلا يملكون
كسف الضر عنكم ولا تحويلا
اولئك
الذين يدعون يبتغون
الى ربهم الوسيله ويرجون
اولئك الذين يدعون يبتغون الى ربهم
الوسيله ايهم اقرب ويرجون
ويرجون رحمته ويخافون عذابه
ان عذاب ربك كان محذورا
ان من قريه الا نحن مهلكوها قبل يوم
القيامه او معذبوها
او معذبوها عذابا
شديدا
كان ذلك في الكتاب مستورا
وما منعنا ان نرسل بالايات الا ان كذب بها
اولون
واتينا
واتينا ثمود الناقه مبصره فظلموا بها
وما نرسل بالايات الا تخويفا
واذ قلنا لك ان ربك احاط بالناس
وما جعلنا الرؤيا التي اريناك الا فتنه
للناس
والشجره الملعونه في القران
ونخوفهم
فما يزيدهم الا طغيانا
كبيرا
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
بسم
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
واذ قلنا للملائكه
اسجدوا لادم فسجدوا الا ابليس
الا ابليس قالجد لمن خلقت طينا
قال ارايتك هذا الذي كرمت علي لئن اخرتني
الى يوم القيامه لاحتنكن
ذريه
هحتلكن
ذريته الا قليلا
قال اذهب فمن تبعك منهم فان جهنم جزاؤكم
جزاء
مغفورا
واستفزز من استطعت منهم بصوتك واجلب عليهم
بخيلك ورجلك وش وشاركهم في الاموال
وشاركهم في الاموال والاولاد وعدهم وما
يعدهم الشيطان الا غرورا
ان عبادي ليس لك عليهم سلطان
وكفى بربك وكيلا
ربكم الذي يسجي لكم الخلق في ربكم الذي
يسجي لكم الفلك في البحر لتبتغوا من فضله
انه كان بكم رحيما
واذا مسكم الضر في البحر ضل من تدعون الا
اياه
فلن نجاكم الى البر اعرضتم
وكان الانسان كفورا
افمن امنتم ان يخسف بكم
اف اامنتم
ان يخسف بكم جانب البر او يوصل عليكم
حاصبا
ثم
لا تجدوا لكم نصيرا
افامنتم
ان يخسف بكم جانب البر او يرسل عليكم
قاصفا
ثم لا تجدوا لكم وكيلاصبا
ثم
[Arabic recitation]
ان يخسف بكم جانب البر او يرسل عليكم
حاصبا
ثم لا تجدوا لكم علينا ثم لا تجدوا لكم
وكيلا
ام امنتم ان يعيدكم فيه تاره اخرى فيرسل
فيرسل عليكم قاصفا
من الريح فيغرقكم
فيغرقكم
بما كفرتم
ثم لا تجدوا لكم علينا به تبيعا
ولقد كرمنا بني ادم وحملناهم في البر
والبحر ورزقناهم
ورزقناهم
من الطيبات وفضلناهم
على كثير ممن خلقنا تفضيلا
يوم ندعو كل اناس بايمانهم
فمن اوتي كتابه بيمينه فاولئك
يقرون كتابهم
فاولئك
يقراون كتابهم ولا يظلمون فتيلا
ومن كان في هذه الدن ومن كان في هذه اعمى
فهو في الاخره اعمى واضل سبيلا
وان كادوا ليفتنونك عن الذي اوحينا اليك
لتفتري علينا غيره
واذا لاتخذوك خليلا
ولولا ان ثبتناك لقد كدت تركن اليهم شيئا
قليلا
اذا لاذقناك ضعف الحياه وضعف الممات
ثم
لا تجد
علينا نصيرا
وان كادوا ليستفزونك
من الارض ليخرجوك منها
ليخرجوك منها ثم واذاك
خل
[Arabic recitation]
سنه
من قد ارسلنا
قبلك من رسلنا
ولا تجد لسنتنا
تحويلا
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
اقم الصلاه لدلوك الشمس الى غس الليل
وقران الفجر وقران الفجر ان قران الفجر
كان مشهودا
ومن الليل فتهجد به نافله لك عسى ان يبعثك
ربك مقاما محمودا
وقل رب ادخلني مدخل صدق
واخرجني مخرج صدق
واجعل لي من لدنك سلطانا
نصيرا
وقل جاء
الحق وزهق الباطل
ان
الباطل كان زهوقا
وننزل من القران ما هو شفاء
ورحمه للمؤمنين
ولا يزيد زيد الظالمين
الا خسارا
واذا انعمنا على الانسان اعرض وناى بجانبه
واذا مسه الشر كان يؤوسا
قل كل يعمل على شاكلته
فربكم
اعلم بمن هو اهدى سبيلا
ويسالونك
عن الروح
قل الروح من امر ربي وما اوتيتم من العلم
الا قليلا
ولئن شئنا لنذهبن
بالذي اوحينا اليك
ثم لا تجد لك به علينا وكيلا
الا رحمه
من ربك
ان فضله كان عليك كبيرا
قل اجتمعت الانس والجن على ان ياتوا بمثل
هذا القران
لا ياتون بمثله ولو كان بعضهم لبعض ظهيرا
ولقد صرفنا للناس في هذا القران من كل مثل
فاى اكثر الناس الا كفورا
وقالوا لن نؤمن لك حتى تفجر لنا من الارض
ينبوعا
او تكون لك جنه
من نخيل وعنب فتفجر الانهار
فتفجر
الانهار خلالها تفجيرا
او تسقط السماء
كما زعمت علينا كسفا
او تاتي بالله والملائكه
قبيلا
او يكون لك بيت من زخرف او ترقى في السماء
ولن نؤمن
لرقيك حتى تنزل علينا كتابا نقراه قل
سبحان ربي هل كنت الا بشرا رسولا
وما منع الناس ان يؤمنوا اذ جاءهم
الهدى الا
الا ان قالوا ابعث الله بشرا رسولا
قل لو كان في الارض ملائكه
يمشون مطمئنين
لنزلنا عليهم من السماء
ملكا رسولا
قل كفى بالله شهيدا بيني وبينكم
انه كان بما تعملون خبيرا
انه
كان بعباده خبيرا
انه كان بعباده
خبيرا بصيرا
ومن يهدي الله فهو المهتد ومن يضلل فلن
تجد لهم من دونه اولياء
ومن يضلل فلن تجد لهم من اولياء
من دونه ونحشرهم يوم القيامه على وجوههم
ونحشرهم يوم القيامه على وجوههم عميا
وبكما وصما
ونحشرهم يوم القيامه على وجوههم عليا
وبكما وصماهم
جهنم
كلما خبت زدناهم
سعيرا
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
يلا
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
have
pleas
‏make
around while we are toay
this is place
this is space and this is a sa book that
is being a real person it's not a tape
recording
if you are bringing your child to the
and you're not teaching them this is a
sacred
‏place
and upst if this
and if this confer we would our kid to
wild make we would so thatent tr could
but here have beingit this is a shared
space this is not fair don't make us be
the bad guys and ‏Pleas
தேங்க்யூ
[Silence]
استووا اعتدلوا
استووا
شيخ فين هو قال 10
الله اكبر
الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
[Arabic recitation]
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم الضالين
امين
ومن يهدي الله فهو المهتدي ومن يضلل فلن
تجد لهم اولياء
من دونه
ونحشرهم يوم القيامه على وجوههم عميا
وبكما وسما
ماواهم جهنم كلما خبت زدناهم سعيرا
ذلك جزاؤهم
بانهم كفروا باياتنا وقالوا ائذا كنا
عظاما ورفاه اانا لمبعوثون خلقا جديدا
اولم يروا ان الله الذي خلق السماوات
والارض قادر على ان يخلق مثلهم وجعل لهم
اجلا لا ريب فيه
فابى الظالمون الا كفورا قل لو انتم
تملكون خزائن
رحمه ربي اذا لامسكتم خشيه الانفاق وكان
الانسان قتورا
ولقد اتينا موسى تسع ايات بينات فاسال بني
اسرائيل
اذ جاءهم
فاسال بني اسرائيل
اذ جاءهم فقال له فرعون اني لاظنك يا موسى
مسحورا
قال لقد علمت ما انزل هؤلاء
الا رب السماوات والارض بصائر
اني لاظنك يا فرعون مثبورا
فاراد ان يستفزهم من الارض فاغرقناه ومن
معه جميعا وقلنا من بعده لبني اسرائيل
اسكنوا الارض فاذا جاء وعد الاخره جئنا
بكم لفيفا
وبالحق انزلناه وبالحق نزل
وما ارسلناك الا مبشرا ونذيرا
وقرانا
فرقناه لتقراه على الناس على مكث ونزلناه
تنزيلا
قل امنوا به او لا تؤمنوا ان الذين اوتوا
العلم من قبله اذا يتلى عليهم يخرون
للاذقان سجدا
ويقولون سبحان ربنا ان كان وعد ربنا
لمفعولا
ويخرون للاذقان يبكون ويزيدهم خشوعا
الله
[Silence]
الله اكبر
قل ادعوا الله او ادعوا الرحمن
ايما تدع فله الاسماء الحسنى ولا تجهر
بصلاتك ولا تخافت بها وابتغ بين ذلك سبيلا
وقل الحمد لله الذي لم يتخذ ولدا ولم يكن
له شريك في الملك ولم يكن له ولي من الذل
وكبره تكبيرا
سبحان الله وبحمده والله اكبر بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله الذي انزل على عبده الكتاب ولم
يجعل له عوجا قيما لينذر باسا شديدا من
لدنه ويبشر المؤمنين الذين يعملون
الصالحات ان لهم اجرا حسنا ماكثين فيه
ابدا وينذر الذين قالوا اتخذ الله ولدا ما
لهم به من علم ولا لابائهم
كبرت كلمه تخرج من افواههم ان يقولون الا
كذبا
فلعلك باخع نفسك على اثارهم ان لم يؤمنوا
بهذا الحديث اسفا
انا جعلنا ما على الارض زينه لها لنبلوهم
ايهم احسن عملا وانا لجاعلون ما عليها
صعيدا
جرزا
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
انا جعلنا ما على الارض زينه لها لنبلوهم
ايهم احسن عملا وانا لجاعلون ما عليها
صعيدا جرزا ام حسبت ان اصحاب الكهف
والرقيم كانوا من اياتنا عجبا اذ اوى
الفتيه الى الكهف فقالوا ربنا اتنا من
لدنك رحمه وهيئ لنا من امرنا رشدا
فاضربنا على اذانهم في الكهف سنين عددا ثم
بعثناهم لنعلم اي الحزبين احصى لما لبثوا
امدا
نحن نقص عليك نباهم بالحق انهم فتيه امنوا
بربهم وزدناهم هدى وربطنا على قلوبهم اذ
قاموا فقالوا ربنا رب السماوات والارض لن
ندعو من دونه الها
لن ندعو من دونه الها لقد قلنا اذا شططا
هؤلاء قومنا اتخذوا من دونه
الهه لولا ياتون عليهم بسلطان بين فمن
اظلم م من افترى على الله كذبا
واذ اعتزلتموهم وما يعبدون الا الله فاووا
الى الكهف ينشر لكم ربكم من رحمته ويهيئ
لكم ويهيئ لكم من امركم مرفقا
وترى الشمس اذا طلعت تزاور عن كهفهم ذات
اليمين واذا غربت تقرضهم ذات الشمال وهم
في فجوه منه ذلك من ايات الله
من يهدي الله فهو المهتدي ومن يضلل فلن
تجد له وليا مرشدا
وتحسبهم ايقاظا وهم رقود ونقلبهم ذات
اليمين وذات الشمال وكلبهم باسط ذراعيه
بالوصيب
لو اطلعت عليهم لوليت منهم فرارا ولملئت
منهم رعبا
وكذلك بعثناهم ليتساءلوا
بينهم قال قائل منهم كم لبثتم قالوا لب
لبثنا يوما او بعض يوم قالوا ربكم اعلم
بما لبثتم فبعثوا احدكم بورقكم هذه الى
المدينه فلينظر
فلينظر ايها ازكى طعاما فلياتكم
برزق منه وليتلطف
وليتلطف ولا يشعرن بكم احدا انهم ان
يظهروا عليكم يرجموكم او يعيدوكم في ملتهم
ولن تفلحوا اذا ابدا
وكذلك اعثرنا عليهم ليعلموا ان وعد الله
حق وان الساعه لا ريب فيها اذ يتنازعون
بينهم امرهم فقالوا ابنوا عليهم بنيانا
ربهم اعلم بهم قال الذين غلبوا على امرهم
لنتخذن
عليهم مسجدا
سيقولون ثلاثه رابعهم كلبهم ويقولون خمسه
سادسهم كلبهم رجما بالغيب
ويقولون سبعه وثامنهم كلبهم قل ربي اعلم
بعدتهم ما يعلمهم الا قليل فلا تمار فيهم
الا
ظاهرا ولا تستفت فيهم منهم احدا
ولا تقولن لشيء اني فاعل ذلك غدا الا ان
يشاء الله
واذكر ربك اذا نسيت وقل عسى ان يهديني ربي
لاقرب من هذا رشدا ولبثوا في كهفهم 300
سنين وازدادوا تسعا قل الله اعلم بما
لبثوا له غيب السماوات والارض ابصر به
واسمع
ابصر به واسمع ما لهم من دونه من ولي ولا
يشرك في حكمه احدا
واتل ما اوحي اليك من كتاب ربك لا مبدل
لكلماته ولن تجد من دونه ملتحدا واصبر
نفسك مع الذين يدعون ربهم بالغداه والعشي
يريدون وجهه
ولا تعت عيناك عنهم تريد زينه الحياه
الدنيا ولا تطع من اغفلنا قلبه عن ذكرنا
واتبع هواه وكان امره فرطا
وقل الحق من ربكم فمن شاء فليؤمن ومن شاء
فليكفر
انا اعتدنا للظالمين نارا احاط بهم
سرادقها
وان يستغيثوا يغاثوا بماء كالمهل يشوي
الوجوه
بئس الشراب وساءت
مرتفقا
ان الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات انا لا
نضيع اجر من احسن عملا اولئك لهم جنات عدن
تجري من تحتهم الانهار
تجري من تحتهم الانهار يحلون فيها من
اساور من ذهب ويلبسون ثيابا خضرا
من سندس واستبرق
متكئين فيها على الارائك
نعم الثواب
نعم الثواب وحسنت مرتفقا
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه اللهشم
[Silence]
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
واضرب لهم مثلا رجلين جعلنا لاحدهما جنتين
من اعناب
وحففناهما بنخل وجعلنا بينهما زرعا كلت
الجنتين اتت اكلها ولم تظلم منه شيئا
وفجرنا خلالهما نهرا وكان له ثمر فقال
لصاحبه وهو يحاوره
فقال لصاحبه وهو يحاوره انا اكثر منك مالا
واعز نفر
ودخل جنته وهو ظالم لنفسه قال ما اظن ان
تبيد هذه ابدا وما اظن الساعه قائمه
ولئن رددت الى ربي لاجدن خيرا منها منقلبا
قال له صاحبه وهو يحاوره اكفرت بالذي خلقك
من تراب ثم من نطفه
ثم من نطفه ثم سواك رجلا
لكن هو الله ربي ولا اشرك بربي احدا ولولا
اذ دخلت جنتك قلت ما شاء الله لا قوه الا
بالله
ان ترني انا اقل منك مالا وولدا فعسى ربي
ان يؤتيني خيرا من جنتك ويرسل عليها
حسبانا من السماء فتصبح صعيدا زلقا
او يصبح ماؤها غورا فلن تستطيع له طلبا
واحيط بثمره فاصبح يقلب كفيه على ما انفق
فيها وهي خاويه على عروشها ويقول
ويقول يا ليتني لم اشرك بربي احدا ولم تكن
له فئه ينصرونه
من دون الله وما كان منتصرا
هنالك الولايه لله الحق هو خير ثوابا وخير
عقبا
واضرب لهم مثل الحياه الدنيا سماء انزلناه
من السماء فاختلط به نبات الارض فاصبح
هشيما تذروه الرياح
وكان الله على كل شيء مقتدرا
المال والبنون زينه الحياه الدنيا
والباقيات الصالحات خير عند ربك ثوابا
وخير املا
ويوم نسير الجبال وترى الارض بارزه
وحشرناهم فلم نغادر منهم احدا وعرضوا على
ربك صفا لقد جئتمونا كما خلقناكم اول مره
بل زعمتم ان لن نجعل لكم موعدا
ووضع الكتاب فترى المجرمين مشفقين مما فيه
ويقولون
ويقولون يا ويلتنا ما لهذا الكتاب لا
يغادر صغيره ولا كبيره الا احصاها
ووجدوا ما عملوا حاضرا
ولا يظلم ربك احدا واذ قلنا للملائكه
اسجدوا لادم فسجدوا الا ابليس كان من الجن
ففسق عن امر ربه
افتتخذونه
وذريته اولياء
من دوني وهم لكم عدو
بئس للظالمين بدلا ما اشهدتهم خلق
السماوات والارض ولا خلق انفسهم
وما كنت متخذ المضلين عضدا
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
بسم الله الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
ويوم يقول نادوا شركائي
الذين زعمتم فدعوهم فلم يستجيبوا لهم
وجعلنا بينهم موقا
وراى المجرمون النار فظنوا انهم مواقعوها
ولم يجدوا عنها مصرفا
ولقد صرفنا في هذا القران للناس من كل مثل
وكان الانسان اكثر شيء جدلا
وما منع الناس ان يؤمنوا اذ جاءهم الهدى
ويستغفروا ربهم الا ان تاتيهم سنه الاولين
او ياتيهم العذاب قبلا
وما نرسل المرسلين الا مبشرين ومنذرين
ويجادل الذين كفروا بالباطل ليدحضوا به
الحق واتخذوا اياتي وما انذروا هزوا
ومن اظلم ممن ذكر بايات ربه فاعرض عنها
ونسي ما قدمت يداه
انا جعلنا على قلوبهم اكنه ان يفقهوه وفي
اذانهم واقرا وان تدعهم الى الهدى فلن
يهتدوا اذا ابدا
وربك الغفور ذو الرحمه لو يؤاخذهم بما
كسبوا لعجل لهم العذاب
بل لهم موعد لن يجدوا من دونه موئلا وتلك
القرى اهلكناهم لما ظلموا وجعلنا لمهلكهم
موعدا
واذ قال موسى لفتا تاه لا ابرح حتى ابلغ
مجمع البحرين او امضي حقبا فلما بلغا مجمع
بينهما نسيا حوتهما فاتخذ سبيله في البحر
سربا فلما جاوزا قال لفتاه اتنا غداءنا
لقد لقينا من سفرنا هذا نصبا
قال ارايت اذ اوينا الى الصخره فاني نسيت
الحوت وما انسانيه الا الشيطان ان اذكره
واتخذ سبيله في البحر عجبا قال ذلك ما كنا
نبغ فارتدا على اثارهما قصصا
فوجدا عبدا من عبادنا اتيناه رحمه من
عندنا وعلمناه من لدنا علما
قال له موسى هل اتبعك على ان تعلمني مما
علمت رشدا
قال انك لن تستطيع معي صبرا وكيف تصبر على
ما لم تحط به خبرا قال ستجدني ان شاء الله
صابرا ولا اعصي لك امرا قال فان اتبعتني
فلا تسالني عن شيء حتى احدث لك منه ذكرا
فانطلقا حتى اذا ركبا في السفينه خرقها
قال اخرقتها لتغرق اهلها لقد جئت شيئا
امرا قال الم اقل انك لن تستطيع معي صبرا
قال لا تؤاخذني بما نسيت ولا ترهقني من
امري عسرا
فانطلقا حتى اذا لقيا غلاما فقتله
قال اقتلت نفسا زكيه بغير نفس لقد جئت
شيئا نكرا قال الم اقل لك انك لن تستطيع
معي صبرا
قال ان سالتك عن شيء بعدها فلا تصاحبني
قد بلغت من لدني اني عذرا
فانطلقا حتى اذا اتيا اهل قريه استطعما
اهلها فابوا ان يضيفوهما
فوجدا فيها جدارا يريد ان ينقض فاقامه قال
لو شئت لاتخذت عليه اجرا قال هذا فراق
بيني وبينك سانبئك بتاويل لما لم تستطع
عليه صبرا
اما السفينه فكانت لمساكين يعملون في
البحر فاردت ان اعيبها وكان وراءهم
ملك ياخذ كل سفينه غصبا
واما الغلام فكان ابواه مؤمنين فخشينا ان
يرهقهما طغيانا وكفرا
فار اردنا ان يبدلهما ربهما خيرا منه زكاه
واقرب رحما
واما الجدار فكان لغلامين يتيمين في
المدينه وكان تحته كنز لهما وكان ابوهما
صالحا
فاراد ربك ان يبلغا اشدهما ويستخرجا
كنزهما رحمه من ربك
وما فعلته عن امري ذلك تاويل ما لم تسطع
عليه صبرا
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
ورحمه ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
احسنت
في ماكنتر
صلاه
ان شاء الله ري ركعه استووا اعتدلوا
الله
اكبر
[Arabic recitation]
الرحمن
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد وايا اياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم قل هو الله احد
الله الصمد لم يلد ولم يولد
ولم يكن له كفوا احد الله اكبر
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
[Arabic recitation]
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم قل اعوذ برب الفلق
من شر ما خلق ومن شر غاسق اذا وقب ومن شر
النفاثات
في العقد قد ومن شر حاسد اذا حسد
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله
قل اعوذ برب الناس
ملك الناس
اله
الناس
من شر الوسواس الخناس
الذي يوسوس في صدور الناس
من الجنه
والناس
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
اللهم اهدنا في من هديت وعافنا فيمن عافيت
وتولنا فيمن توليت
وبارك لنا فيما
اعطيت
وقنا شر ما قضيت
فانك
تقضي ولا يقضى عليك
انه لا يذل من واليت
ولا يعز من عاديت
تباركت
ربنا وتعاليت
لا ملجا ولا منجا منك الا اليك
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبرلام
[Silence]
واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ش
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
سبحان الملك القدوس سبحان الملك القدوس
سبحان
الملك القدوس
[Silence]
جز الله